you might not know about me I'm a wii u
owner I own a wii-u do you own a wii-u
peter brian by proxy my roommate has one
your ears here's the one we you have
souls yeah fair enough i'm at uh
Spinelli do you own a Wii U yes I do
yeah would you consider yourself a
Nintendo fan kind of yeah a little bit
what was it that got you to buy we're
actually the main reason why bottle Wii
U is for Bayonetta 2 X oh yeah good shot
at ten at a ten on gamespot com but you
know before we started handing the
matter like I can't Cassidy regime Danny
get used to it yeah I take your van
award and peter brian Kevin I miss you
yeah what was it that made you get away
you your voyage i'm going to i moved
into an apartment but I moved into that
apartment because of how do we okay yeah
is this josh is we you yes it is josh
why did you fire with you when winwaker
alright good chef ah but if i didn't
have one to use i would buy one mmm and
why would you bother gateway um well
partially because it's my job but I
think Nintendo has a ton of excellent
exclusives and that obviously you can't
get anywhere else because they're there
Nintendo and their exclusive and there's
such interesting games and Mario makers
one of them the most recent one I think
is a probably underestimated by the
audience at large he's probably looking
in like okay it's mario game where you
can drag and drop items big deal but
huge implications in terms of like you
know the amount of gameplay you can get
out of a single game and how creative
you know different people can get and
you can sample that creativity you know
from people around the world and to me
that is a very enticing thing but i
could see how people who aren't really
into nintendo exclusives might avoid the
wii u because frankly it just doesn't
get as many you know triple a big games
that you can guarantee will be on x1
xbox one in PS yeah and i'm interested
madden what it's kind of a funny story
angle that you have because the reason
you bought it was actually because of a
third party game which nintendo didn't
develop on their own right and what
other games the owner you were you like
what you like doing on your wii u's when
you go back to every couple of months so
do you play every now and again well
other than being a day actually i think
i own wonderful 101 well
okay like I do i do buy a couple like
Nintendo games from time to time one of
the major series I'm more like a fan of
his Legend of Zelda floors but it the
system isn't really one I like always
constantly come back to you it's just
it's only whenever like you know they'll
release some kind of charming cute
adorable sort of like you touch like
exclusive title that I'll be like okay
it's time to go play the wii u again
it's like a tentpole game sort of system
it's like I sometimes I kind of forget I
have one for a little while and then
something comes out like my American
it's like oh great I get to play this
for a couple of weeks or like mario kart
was another at great game which everyone
was playing forever like New Super Mario
Brothers was kind of a little bit okay
it's like turning in their tuning into
like a TV channel you'd never watched
because they're playing the thing or
something yeah oh I love that movie I'm
gonna tune in just for this and then
quietly never return so it's sold 10
million units it came as November 2012
actually nice so like almost almost
three years ago yeah and the ps4
comparative Leah sold 25 million units
the xbox one we don't know exactly what
we're me around the 15 million mark and
people are thinking and what do you
think it was was that sort of the reason
why the wii u didn't catch on Peter what
what is it that sort of considering the
massive success of the we didn't carry
over for the wii u there are three
reasons I think one is what I mentioned
earlier is that people know that they're
not going to be getting the exclusive or
the games from you know it can be soft
ETA like all those big publishers on the
wii u because of reason to it's a
significantly under powered machine when
compared to playstation 4 and xbox one
and obviously it came out sooner but
people understood that those consoles
were coming yeah and and i think when
they may coupled that with the other
fact i just mentioned they probably
decided to wait for the more powerful
system but lastly i think the gamepad is
sort of an underwhelming offering
considering you know they're following
the wii with the wiimote which was such
a revolutionary thing do even though it
didn't make sense at first it caught on
and i think people were expecting
something that would match that or Trump
that and what they got was a very
uncomfortable controller that is a slow
tablet yeah so yeah i just i think the
entire thing is underpowered and was
perhaps rush to market it's tough to say
but that too
is why the wii u just isn't doing so hot
it's interesting about the tablet
because I friends over on the weekend
who don't play games and they sat down
in front of my television it's all these
council sitting there and she points
adopting she's what the hell is that oh
it's the Wii U and she said oh it's like
an ipod for your wii and i was like no
no no yeah it's a different thing and
she's like oh so it's like they made a
portable version like no no no there's
an actual console here this is the
controller like just the fact that it
took three questions to try and
communicate like what that is matt is
there any game like do you have any
future for your wii u is there any game
you're looking forward to that's coming
out over the next while like does mario
maker interest you oh yeah yeah i mean
i'm definitely interested in picking up
Super Mario maker but other than that
just the next election is elegant to be
honest which do you think it'll come out
on the way you yeah I mean the other
yeah that's true we have just a twilight
princess scenario where it does come out
on the wii u and on the NX but we still
have no idea what he'll the NX is so it
may just be a wii u title yeah did you
have any sort of idea or any sort of
insight or maybe just a gut feeling on
when we'll see the MX you think of
something y su cara mia moda told me
yesterday christmas 2060 is it something
you think we'll see at e3 next year like
they've been talking about it yeah
couple years yeah oh yeah year in a
change worried you're going to see it at
a Nintendo Direct during a slow point in
the year or we're going to see it at e3
I don't think it makes sense for them to
do anything at TGS because Nintendo
basically ignores TGS yeah strange yeah
but it's you know bud Chronicles X is
coming on December grey and that looks
awesome in another like 100 our game but
yeah I'm super served for that I'm
looking that's probably apart from Zelda
the only way you game laughter that I am
interested in yeah I've still got a
bunch more to nestle not like dovin into
for whatever reason it always seems to
be like the B console to whatever is
happening on my pc or ps4 xbox one right
like Donkey Kong tropical freeze its
lava really delving into like I got it
and then just played a little bit but
it's weird it's like a bee console for
so many people but so many of the games
that are exclusive to it are like they
pack in so much charm and invented
little gameplay mechanics that you just
you kind of don't find elsewhere it's
it's still amazing to me that a company
that is able to do that as well
nintendo get good shot there yeah you
know can't find a market for for these
games and it's just the changing face of
gaming becoming more mainstream i think
where people want the Hollywood
experience and a nintendo DS hasn't
really captured that as well as other
publishers yeah when they think about
some of the directions which sort of
lied to know like the the other consoles
are going with like a bigger support on
indie games like sort of bolstering
their lineups and like the massive
growth we're seeing in pc with like
smaller type games and like games that
people play for years and years like
it's almost like the wii is tapping into
like it's almost like there's a
communication problem where people of
our generation get why the wii u work so
that we works but for the younger crowd
that's just this weird relic of a sort
of an older type of video game i will
tell you this though my nephew who is
i'd say seven years old all he wants for
christmas is a wii u not really that is
the only thing he wants an attitude yeah
he wants it primarily for Skylanders
Disney infinity but also splatoon Wow
well tuned is something that is really
resonated with him and I talked to him
once in a while and a lot of his friends
play that game I think Nintendo has
actually done a great job of capturing
maybe a modest-sized audience of a
younger generation with splatoon that I
think we don't see that's bizarre it's
sort of the reverse situation I'm when I
was up packs as well last week or the
weekend before last the amount of the
toon car thing that was going I was
actually a little alarming was like oh
wow a lot of people now have you played
that at all mad a little bit of my
friends house yeah they so it's really
good actually it's just like that it
seems to have like a set of like a
decent amount of games that's getting
bigger bigger bigger but I just feel
like closer we get to the NX the least
chance this console has like are we sort
of like we're done with growth on wii u
like you think people gonna pick it up
over the next year so before we hear
more about the next people will pick it
up but that's not going to be enough to
really create like a trend like an
upward trend in sales right i mean i
think you know nintendo is still making
money off the we you with with game
sales i think that's that's evident
their hardware at this point is so
outdated that i'm sure it's really cheap
to produce and the course are making a
lot of money with the 3ds in those games
so I mean it's not killing Nintendo but
I
they're giving as much support as they
need to up until the annex is available
but I am concerned about the NX and I
just it's hard to see how Nintendo is
going to turn things around when it
comes to the perception of such a large
audience like millions of people day one
not over the course of four years yeah
with a trickle of games they have to do
it day one and if they don't do it this
time but the NX is probably to be their
last console do you think I'm post-it
wats a Nintendo will struggle even more
but I get to bring that up I'd like you
thinking about like he was such a
massive core no wind sock or guiding
elements to their to their company that
like yeah like you have to imagine like
he was really like you know deep into
the MX um you know I don't imagine that
he is the linchpin you know I obviously
his absence is going to leave you know a
void in Nintendo and how they do things
but but there's I think they have the
ability to to do something intelligent
if they take their time and do things
right i mean we saw sony do it with the
playstation 4 that we have mark Cerny to
develop that hardware because the ps3
was a complicated expensive assistant to
develop for so if sony can turn it
around hardware wise by taking a
different route I think Nintendo can as
well but I don't know if they will cool
I guess time will tell mountain Peter
thank you so much going on talking I
have a mess about Mario maker and the
wii u and let us know what you think
about whe you do you play one yourself
do you own one do you own wanna not play
games are you playing my ohmic right now
I let us know in the comments below